well it's been a long day full of
insight conflicting insights our friend
and now in this last session we're not
going to try to have the nice synthesis
where we bring everybody together in the
easy shallow consensus I'm sure we'll
still have a lot of discussions but for
that I'm glad that we have two panelists
with when who are both in their own ways
actually quite exceptional when Claire
Lockhart she's a co-founder and CEO of
the Institute for state effectiveness
with rob Johnny who was the first
minister of finance of the new
Afghanistan and well everybody knows the
book chico sign with a job fixing fail
states a framework for rebuilding a
fractured word world she certainly one
of the person who has given the most
thought to both to Afghanistan and to
the broader issue of how a fragile state
has a a called can be consolidated put
together and out the difficult
relationship between foreigners in a
country that they want to help Jane chin
has had then most interesting career
chaya checkered past shake it fast
working at the State Department being a
very successful Silicon Valley
entrepreneur being a national
intelligence officer for East Asia at
the CIA and then assistant secretary for
Asia at the Pentagon and now a professor
at Princeton and I'm happy to say a
partner in the task force at the Century
Foundation on Afghanistan I want to
mention the century foundation because
when several of the speakers today have
been working on that collective effort
of the Century Foundation to make sense
of a minister
oh gee for Afghanistan and so I think
the wealth of information in this panel
also something to have in the work of
the Century Foundation I want to pay
tribute to the foundation then to Jeff
Laurenti who is here today from the
foundation with the Michael Hannah and
so first i will ask claire loca to speak
and injunction and then i'll try to put
together all that and open for last
round of question Claire thank you for
the for the opportunity to provide some
reflections I think I've gana some might
be at its second open moment in the last
decade the first open moment being after
the tragedy of 911 when the bond
agreement was put together when there
was an enormous amount of hope from
certainly within the population that
things would be different the trajectory
went in one direction and then another
now there's a commitment of an
extraordinary amount of forces and
resources that frankly wasn't there in
the first five years after after 2001
but there's a real question about what
kind of trajectory that the future work
will go in in from now on and a lot of
unknowns and I think we certainly know
from looking back over the last decade
that human agency and leadership are
really very very important um today
we've heard both a lot of optimism and a
lot of pessimism and I wonder whether we
don't need to bring these into some kind
of balance we must be realistic nobody's
I don't think was ever talking about but
certainly isn't now about building a
Switzerland or Valhalla divorced from
reality so there's enormous need to be
realistic and have a realistic analysis
of what's happening on the ground but I
think we should also recognize that
pessimism can be a self-fulfilling
prophecy certainly when I first won a
scholarship to come and study in the
states I was encouraged absolutely have
rigorous criticism
up to a third of your time but be sure
to spend at least two-thirds of your
time looking for ways to overcome the
constraints you've identified and
looking for possible pathways forward
which i think is the purpose of of this
session some things we can't know about
the future I personally think we can't
know what trajectory for example a
Taliban fractional or group that were
dataform part of a coalition government
will take over part of the country what
way they will go I don't think that's
something we can know some things that
we do know we do know that the future
will happen and we know that somewhere
between 25 and 30 million afghans the
reality of the current visa regimes
won't get visas to go elsewhere the will
be 25 million afghans also living in
that in that place the future will
happen and I think it's imperative to
sink through over the next 5 10 15 years
what type of trajectories we might see
I'm going to take a brief detour into
the past and then look forward at some
of the elements that it might be useful
or imperative to think about briefly
delving into the past over the last 10
years and this is from the perspective
of somebody who had had the privilege to
be part of many discussions on both in
New York at the UN and and then on the
ground in Afghanistan with the Afghan
cabinet with the UN the World Bank and
other actors certainly between 2001 and
2005 there was a sense that the country
was moving in a forward in a positive
direction I think something snapped and
the trajectory reversed at about 2005 I
the privileges in both lloyd Jagger's of
the main droid jirgas in in 2002 and
2004 then district head after district
head stood up including in from those
districts which are now immersed in
insurgency and pledged their support to
the process like Tara Brahimi recently
reflected on on those Lloyd records and
described the reality of the atmosphere
and the sense that the country was
pulling together by 2006 the same
district leaders were saying you
betrayed us
somes something was snapped at trust was
lost a sense of broken promises so the
peace process was not consolidated now
one of what were the roots of what went
wrong I think this will be debated by
historians foot for decades to come and
his historians rightly say we can't tell
we can't write the history until 30
years past but I think with two major
components the failure to adapt a
culture of warlordism and bring it
within a culture of rule of law and we
heard ambassador haleh's odds reflect on
some of these dimensions as for why this
happened and it's not unique to
Afghanistan we see it in revolutionary
resistance movements around the world
when they take power when they when they
come into positions of authority they
find it psychologically extremely
difficult to adapt to bureaucratic and
democratic governance procedures after
having led a top-down revolutionary
resistance movement or being parties to
a civil war and the second I think the
second major failure was a way that we
tipped billions of dollars collectively
into an aid aid complex that wasn't
devoted in reality to building
institutions it actually assets stripped
and undermined them and marginalize the
people so going forward I'll quickly go
through five dimensions and I think
we've heard each of them reflected today
and I'll look particularly it to the
so-called civilian side although I
absolutely recognize as we reflected on
that you can divorce the political and
the military the use of force has to be
bounded by its political objective and
to separate them as force the first is
the need for a regional approach
ambassador Brahimi has been the first to
admit that mistakes were made during the
bomb process but as an observer what he
did i'll say that one of the things he
did most brilliantly was put the region
first so while he had members of the p5
including Britain and France practically
beating down his door he went to the
region with some colleagues and he built
a regional framework with Iran with
Pakistan with the northern neighbors
with China and got them on board and on
the ground both the diplomacy and the
economic constructs between 2001 5 put
the region first
after 2006 for some reason i think it
was partly because of the insurgency
because of nato coming to the fore it
was it became a US Europe Canada
construct and the region was
inadvertently perhaps left out of the
construct so that when the region our
ambassadors were convened a couple of
months ago it was the first time they'd
met in five years so no wonder and I
think as we heard in the regional panel
there's a sense of being left out of not
being consulted so going forward one of
the imperatives is to think about what
kind of diplomatic and economic
construct to build that engages the
region appropriately it's happening
already within the region will start
with Eric and others but how to
establish that in the role of the UN
being indispensable to that the second I
think we need to potentially absolutely
to recognize the centrality of Afghan
politics in the Afghan political reality
and perhaps while there may need to be
some kind of deal move away from seeing
that as the whole piece and perhaps
moving away from a political settlement
capital P capital s to a sense of a
political process or political processes
and one with our inclusive perhaps
reframing the issue to one looks at as
ambassador stephane de Mistura the
current SRSG says what do the Afghans
want what's the framework for all
Afghans and that perhaps needs to come
first and within that construct how do
we develop a processes for listening to
understanding and redressing grievances
of the pashtun population as a whole of
passion populations and different groups
and citizens in general and see rep
there for reconciliation in its broader
sense of different constituencies of the
population coming term to terms with
each other in the past and not just
looking only to a narrow group an Afghan
civil society leader recently said in
any society that are 1% thugs four
percent extremists and ninety-five
percent ordinary people he said the
problem comes in Afghanistan when we
give the power and the money in the guns
to the one percent who are press the
ninety-five percent who are left with
nowhere to go except ally themselves
with the extremists and I
fear that sometimes we fall into that
pattern it's easy to do so third the
question of State Building and the
public administration not talking about
a Switzerland or Valhalla but any
country on the world and that were a
world is built on the Constituent units
of sovereign functioning states and any
country needs to perform at least the
minimum set of responsibilities to its
people in the international community I
fear at the moment there are thousands
of small projects and initiatives which
are being pursued without a sense of the
whole if one in when ones in Kabul if
you ask people does anyone have a map of
governance an org chart of the
government no one's yet been able to
produce one we have a fashion for the
provinces one year then it's the
district's then it's the village but how
does it fit together and I think that
sense is needed now what are the rules
of the game so that Afghans can govern
themselves and not it's not a question
of centralization versus
decentralization but which functions
should be performed at which level and I
think the real missing dimension in
thinking about the public administration
is that the public administration isn't
an abstract thing it's actually run by
people and one of the in most enormous
neglects has been the human capital of
the country the needs assessment process
of the UN in the World Bank the UN
agencies in the world bank in 2002
tilled the Afghan government you're not
allowed to invest in any money for any
education over the age of 11 for Afghans
so the Afghan budget officers took out
funding to the secondary schools and
polytechnics and vocational schools that
already existed now we complain several
years on that Afghans have no capacity
we spend billions of dollars bringing in
from the outside last year the higher
education budget for the country and
vocational training was 35 million
dollars I think until this is a dress
it's no wonder that generals across the
country complaining there are no nurses
there are no doctors there are no
teachers for the schools and clinics
that are being built a major lacuna and
then I think the of the functioning of a
minimally sovereign state is fundamental
but I think the paradox perhaps might be
is that the entry point comes from two
other dimensions and perhaps we've
neglected these nasha Afghani and I
sometimes reflect that we would focus
much more not on
State Building per se but the balance of
the state the market and civil society
so the market the economy Afghanistan
does have the potential to be
self-sufficient in revenue terms and I
believe that the next year provides the
opportunity to develop and put in place
a minerals governance framework for the
at least one two three trillion dollars
of potential minerals and it's not just
the mineral the revenue from the
minerals itself it's the fact that the
minerals provides the basis for the
development of infrastructure which self
opens up the country the revenue will
come from trade and customs revenue when
Afghanistan is increasingly integrated
into the flows of global trade and as
one American commentator recently said
oh it's not about us leaving and turning
the lights off we can actually leave and
leave the lights on if the elements of a
functioning economy can be put in place
and then just closing on and the society
dimension coin actually recognizes the
population it argues for a population
centric approach I wonder on these the
so-called civilian side if we haven't
neglected but the population we're
talking about the state in such abject
abstract terms about connecting the
government to the people that we've
forgotten that the people aren't a sack
of potatoes that their agents themselves
and a recent gathering of civil society
leaders from Afghanistan met outside the
country recently and really boom owned
the fact that the space for civil
society had been closed down and I
wonder whether the international
community hasn't been complicit in that
by talking and conceptualizing the state
in these top down almost autocratic
terms so I question what's the role
going forward for organizations like the
UN to recognize that their loyalty to in
the space for the people in civil
society in general and recognize with it
and the attitude the people and their
actions and activities that will make
the state function or not thank you
thank you Jim
i will first of all apologize for my
voice while you all were having lunch i
was at my doctors office being diagnosed
with bronchitis when I told him I was
coming to a panel he gave me some
zithromax when I told him the topic was
peace in Afghanistan he offered some
valium but my task from jean-marie today
was actually not to present a reasoned
case but he told me to listen carefully
to the panel's during the day and try
and extract some conclusions about some
conclusions or implications about what
was said for the process that might
bring about peace in Afghanistan and so
I have listened to carefully during the
day I confess to being stilken somewhat
confused as lacked our Brahimi often
says because we have spent time
traveling together he says I I thank you
very much I'm still confused but now i
am confused in a much more sophisticated
way and the question of the road ahead
is a hard one debt to answer
particularly when there's so much
disagreement about where we are though
there's more agreement on on how we got
there certainly agreement all the
mistakes that were made along the way I
don't know about you but I was most
impressed bye bye tzelek al-assad's very
frank sort of forensic analysis of the
bond process and some of the failings in
two thousand three four and five you
remember he he initially defined these
three lines of operations that had to be
conducted more or less simultaneously in
order to execute a strategy and Afghan
one was the military piece one was the
domestic political piece and a third of
course was the regional diplomatic piece
he gave us sort of a b-plus on the
military side and I think he gave us a
low c SB United States since this tends
to be a us-centric conversation kind of
a low c on the political domestic
political and the regional diplomatic
efforts and it went downhill from there
with the very few exceptions perhaps
Colonel George and Dante paradiso most
of the panelists would have assigned
even lower grades to to the
effectiveness with which those three
lines of operations were be were pursued
so the question mark then is going
forward how do you what's the prospects
what are the prospects for a strategy
that in fact integrates these three
lines of operation that would have
reasonable possibility of bringing about
a piece equilibrium not unlike the one
just described by by Claire Lockhart and
I would venture 33 modest observations
that integrate some of these comments
the the first one I guess goes back to
fundamental strategy so so we're at sepa
here and sefa probably has a course on
strategy 101 and there's it probably
says in strategy 101 that whatever your
line of operation is whether its
military economic development political
development or regional diplomacy
whatever your line of operation is you
need first of all have a clear strategy
what are your objectives you need to
have clarity about the method you need
to have it's sufficiently resourced to
achieve the objectives and perhaps most
importantly is the fourth variable
particularly with respect to Afghanistan
which is time you need to apply the
resources long enough in the method that
you've chosen to achieve the objectives
that you've reduced in your strategy for
starters and this most professors of IR
I think would orbit strata strategy
studies
would would argue is invariant whether
you're dealing with Afghanistan or
Guatemala but you're any other crisis so
to me listening to most of the
discussions today it's pretty clear that
that the time variable is probably where
the strategy will right into the ground
the clear implication of most of the
speakers was that the problem the
underlying problem of Afghanistan in
terms of the destruction of human
capital terms of the damage done
physical and and institutional is so
deep and the centrality of Pakistan is
Pakistan is so close as a shadow over
this that there is probably not enough
time for a us-centric strategy to
achieve a certainly not if not a victory
of military of victory as conventionally
divined but probably not even the first
outcome that shielded on Soto suggests
was one of the three possible ways this
could play out if that's true then the
implications for and this is my second
point the implications for the prospects
for peace of Afghanistan becomes much
less of a us or nato LED process and
devolves much more for better or for
worse but into the hands of the Afghans
all the belligerents in Afghanistan the
Karzai government the Northern Alliance
the Quetta Shura konnie huq matera all
the players with the Pakistanis looking
over their shoulder and meddling
probably ona on a semi permanent basis
but where does that leave you and again
listening to many of the speakers and a
number of the questions including some
of the most interesting questions that
weren't answered the clear implication
is that there are probably as many
actors in in this war powerful actors in
this war with an incentive to sustain
the conflict than there are for those
who would like to have it brought to
equilibrium all right i think i heard
that either by this data directly or
implied several times some of them some
of them motivated by the sheer amount of
money that's cascading through the
landscape others like the
narcotraficantes who would just as soon
have a low-grade war in most of the
country so they can get on with their
business the peace peace isn't good if
you own a security firm or if you for
that matter for the Pakistanis Christine
could talk about this a greater length
about about the political and economic
consequences of this vast chain of
containers enroute from Karachi through
torkham gates fanning out through the
rest of the country but the bottom line
is you have at least for some
indeterminate period of time a large
number of actors who have a greater
motivation for sustained warfare than
for peace and they are likely because of
the asymmetries of Afghan politics to
outweigh what Michael simple described
in his discussion as this constituency
for peace which is probably I'm sure
you're right probably statistically for
more Afghans believe that to be the case
but for the moment those with an
incentive for sustained conflict to have
the money and the guns so where does
this leave you it would suggest if you
combine that with the first point which
is the the the long trajectory of
declining Western enthusiasm and support
and commitment to the Afghan cause you
combine that with the the large number
of parties who have an interest in
sustained
conflict at some point you would deduce
that the parties interested in sustained
conflict will realize that the game is
ending that the the the the money
machine and the violence machine is is
petering out at which point they will be
faced with the choice a lot of choices
and it won't be one group making one
choice at one time then a date in like
framework would there be a lot of
choices probably in a somewhat messy
decentralized process and the choice
will be again I think a lonely the lines
described by Zeile Durant's aura which
is they could continue in the face of
dwindling dwindling assets from the
outside both military and and economic
to engage to treat Afghanistan like the
object of Abbas continued Buzkashi game
and we've seen this movie before or they
would decide that they'd probably make
sense for them in the long run that
their personal and their national
interests are optimized by pursuing some
kind of equilibrium peace accord whether
that's a fake accord or a temporary
accord as you'll described or whether
that is an accord that has firmer
foundations and a higher probability of
being sustained it's hard to tell
they're probably they'll probably be a
range of choices but having been old
enough myself to have been in Vietnam in
1974 and having watched the first piece
of cord crumble my guess is that there
may be several iterations before you
have a final equilibrium which brings me
to the third and and final conclusion to
draw from this conversation which is I
guess more to the Mandate of visual
memories center for international
conflict resolution
which presumably are the recipes that
you try to apply using the best lessons
that you can from where it's worked
elsewhere and also trying to avoid the
things that didn't work in other
conflict resolution circumstances I
think the first the the first big take
away the first implication would be that
to the degree that that your general
petraeus or you are Richard Holbrooke or
are you are some other I staff related
official who takes this seriously if you
accept these first two points then it
tells you that you need to construct the
strategy by which you conduct those
three lines of operation the military
piece the domestic political negotiation
piece and certainly the regional
diplomatic beats particularly the
Pakistan diplomatic piece with a clear
eye to what kind of an equilibrium
condition that you want which woody
means to say that you are in a difficult
situation of using decreasing
application of resources both soldiers
and money in order to get people to do
what you want them to do
but that's the hand that has to be
played the corollary to that is that you
therefore did have a very clear idea of
what the political endgame is which
means that you need to engage the other
actors in this game who can bring about
police have a reasonable chance of both
filling out the stakes of all the other
actors and perhaps beginning the process
of a diplomatic reconciliation whether
you call it bond to or something else
and that's when you try to perhaps to
get lacto brandy back in the game get
them suited up again and put them on as
put them on as you and jet maybe even
get John Murray back back back back in
the game but you take it seriously and
you start to take it seriously now I
don't know if I like the last point well
I was just calculating that time the 14
speaker so it's it's a double
challenging task because when I to say
something new after I mean as the number
14 is probably impossible and also you
may begin to have an overdose of
Afghanistan so I'll just try to make a
few simple points one that strikes me is
how feckle we are that is I've looked at
Afghanistan ever since to 2001 and on
the shifting evolving goals about
Afghanistan it was obviously it was a
reaction to the tragedy of 911 but it
was immediately packaged in a much
broader and grandiose scheme of social
engineering that we were going to
rebuild a new Afghanistan the cover page
of Time magazine that i was mentioning
this morning to get us started and now
we tend to move from one extreme
in to the other it's Bruins proven
difficult to re-engineer Afghanistan we
haven't had the fortitude the
persistence the coherence the humidity
that is needed for such an ambitious
goal and so now we go back to square one
and say well just let's make sure that
some al-qaeda training base is not
reestablished in Afghanistan and I think
it's a kind of binary approach with
which I take actually very strong
exception to be honest I think this way
of opposing well either we if we can't
have victory then let's pack up and
leave but making sure that our car dad
hasn't set foot I don't think that's a
good way rain the discussion that's my
first point and when my first point is
linked to the second which is that the
confusion in our war goals so to speak
is linked to a broader issue which is
the shifting balance of power in the
world there was a lot of discussion
today on Dazz afghanistan per se matter
or not and we are quite confused about
that and I think you're confused because
the world is indeed moving it's a clich
to say that Asia is is rising two days
ago i was i was in dubai and when dubai
is a very strange place a very
artificial in many ways but there's one
thing you feel very strongly in Dubai
where you you see Russians use the
Chinese you see a lot of people from the
Middle East obviously you see in Dubai
how the the sort of center of gravity of
the world is is moving and Afghanistan
is part of that story it's part of that
story in a very concrete manner as you
see
pakistan and iran vying for min the
being in the Gateway to Central Asia
with competing harbors on the I mean I
don't know if we won her as can call it
the Indian Ocean but certainly I mean in
the in the warm waters of the south of
the up south of central Central Asia
Afghanistan's very much a part of that
because depending on how Afghanistan
stabilizes or doesn't stabilize I mean
the pipeline's will be built in one way
or another in different harbours will be
the exit to that part of the world where
I mean considerable natural resources
have been have been found the way China
will use the Malacca Strait or will go
through different roads also is linked
to Afghanistan and we are confused about
that and that impacts on policies
because we continue to think of a gas as
if one country the United States could
shape the outcome I think Claire said
very rightly that in the early days of
the men born there was a conscious
effort to bring the whole region
together and it's clear that today any
any way forward for Afghanistan requires
to integrate such issues as of course
and that was extensively discussed today
the pakistan-india rivalry but also the
Pakistan Iran rival driver I'm in the
rivalry also the Central Asia dimension
that we discussed all that I mean all
these countries have their own bilateral
issues and
Afghanistan is part of that equation and
so a country like the United States of
course no solution no way forward will
be found without the support of the
United States but that's but the support
of the United State doesn't mean that
the United States as powerful as it is
can shape the outcome that outcome will
be the product of a much more complex
picture where all China where Pakistan
where India where Iran where turkey will
have a say and not to mention the
Central Asian countries that were
discussed this afternoon and that makes
for a much more confusing picture but
that makes one point that is Afghanistan
matters and matters in a much deeper way
than just as a place where some al-qaeda
base might or might not be reestablished
and in that sense it means that the
force discussion between do we care
about Afghanistan because we have a
generous heart and we don't want those
people to which we in a way we brought
war do we do we we care just out of the
goodness of our art or do we care
because there are strategic implications
it's a forced economy in a way
Afghanistan matters because we meddle
with Afghanistan and Afghanistan matters
because it's part it's at the inch of
Asia the Middle East and that region
cannot be ignored my third point which
in some ways is linked to the second is
that governance for the reason I just
stated is as much a strategic as a
humanitarian goal and they I would want
to go to follow up on the discussion
between the local and the national that
animated
panels part of the afternoon I mean it
was said and I very much agree with that
that I mean the talibans with all their
men complexities and we all know that
when it's a very it's so loose and
complicated issue and that I mean as
Michaels i was saying i mean the Akane
network is when this thing from the
Quetta Shura in gulbuddin Hekmatyar is
out there in in one particular part of
them in the eastern Afghanistan we all
know the the new yours of that at the
same time there is such a thing as a
national political project and because
there is that that means that any effort
just to to build a nation by a series of
of local deals I mean there is something
fundamentally missing there and more
than that I think of the French
experience in Algeria with where there
was a lot of attempts to sort of get
defectors from the movement the FLN the
momentum in the the algerian fighters
who were fighting the French rule that I
mean some of those efforts were quite
successful and it's a normal part of a
military strategy to try to get people
on the other side to defect I mean it's
I mean who wouldn't do it but at the
same time it is not a political strategy
and when you have a national movement at
some point you have to ask yourself in
weather that can be the whole strategy
whether it can really be be successful
and coming back to my governance point
what that means is that governance
having him in what Claire was describing
is not just about robbing the Taliban of
their support by building institutions
around which the people will rally it's
also creating a base around which a
negotiation I mean some measure of
national consensus can be built because
the Taliban will never negotiate and
come to any agreement with a government
that they despise and so building a
measure of credibility for a government
is part of a negotiating strategy not
just to weaken the adversary but to
build a platform with which you can
negotiate with the adversary now what
does that mean in operational terms I
think it's all about the time frame this
is something that was alluded to
throughout the day but I would want to
to go a little to push on that
particular point we tend to think again
in binary terms either we shoot them or
we negotiate and we're looking for the
kind of data and moment in Afghanistan
that is not going to come that is I
think from everything we heard today
it's very unlikely that a Dayton moment
is coming it's very unlikely because
when you look at the preconditions of
both sides they're just totally
incompatible one side says well you have
them in the you have to support the
Constitution you
have to essentially accept the framework
as is and the other side says Karzai we
never we're never going to deal with
that person fine troops we know we're
not going to to enter into any political
discussion as long as there are foreign
troops so I mean they there is no
overlap between the position of the two
sides at the moment and that means that
what is most likely is that we have to
gear form in a protracted and that I
very much even agree with what Jim was
saying on that point we have to gear for
a rather painful protracted multi-year
period of both and not an alternative of
both military engagement and political
engagement now the political engagement
at the moment isn't there and that's a
problem in my personal in my personal
view that's a big that's a big problem
but what that means is that fighting is
going to continue and negotiating more
accurately talking before negotiating
probably proximity talks and that's why
at some point the UN will probably be
involved your knee you will need a third
party because you know in a in a moment
you know in a context of war talking
would be talking directly would be a
sign of weakness and so none of the
fighting parties will want to talk
directly and that's a very strong
argument for a third impartial party
such as the UN with all the
complications of them in the present
mandate of you nama in support of one of
the parties as was said I think by
Michael sample but the UN as an
organized in the Security Council as
probably will have to get involved
because of that incompatibility
and because of the fact that direct
negotiation would send the wrong signal
in terms of commitment on both on both
sides and the question again of
timeframe is the sequence do you I mean
will we inflict on ourselves what in a
way we inflicted on the Soviet Union
that is not to have a real solid deal
before the Soviet Union left which
didn't lead to great results frankly for
Afghanistan and for the international
community or will we be an enlightened
enough to understand that that
engagement needs to need to to a real
political conclusion before the troops
start leaving that will be the essence
but for that to happen and I'll stop
there that requires a much broader
support than just a national decision at
the United States it requires in a way
and understanding those countries like
China like Pakistan like India like the
Europeans to come together on that
strategy at the moment there is no such
a thing and i would say therefore that
the the real priority is on the one hand
to continue the long slog in afghanistan
but on the other to start in earnest the
political engagement the political
engagement at the global level because
the very disjointed situation at the
moment at the at the global level is not
a foundation for any solid process which
will be which will not be again 13 month
process
but a several years process so I'll stop
there and well it's it's almost five
past five so we we have them in if you
are brave enough you can ask questions
and we can continue to a pathetic please
I 15 15 if that's ok but I'll have to be
5 15 years ok
let me just throw in the issue of the
domestic politics United States which
can enter this in all sorts of
unpredictable ways I'd like you all to
speculate on how you see that working
we've just had at a wild 2010 election
we could have another wild 2012 election
and a question of who lost Iraq you know
to the Iranians or who lost Afghanistan
whatever I mean these kind of things
could enter in all sorts of crazy ways
and how would that affect all this
because it could completely change the
nature what you're talking about Jim I
know you will have to leave at five
fifteen you want to comment on that I
have no comparative advantage and
answering that question Claire why is it
for a Frenchman to comment on as my
daughter would say no fair well I mean
that frankly I I do think that the the
the president evolution of American
politics does complicate the picture
because if we're talking about political
engagement it's it's easy to make a case
on behalf of a sort of a purist view of
in the Afghanistan that we're just
selling out to Afghanistan and so in
that sense I think it's not going to be
easy for any US leader to to manage
those two tracks of the military track
and the end the political track because
the political track can easily be
understood as selling out which I don't
think it is but it can easily be
portrayed as such but I'm not a great
expert on American politics i have no
comparative advantage as Jim would say
my to cope analysts are not eager to
comment on the
well I think very right to raise the
issue i think it was interesting that
one of the first statements that the
republican Republicans made on
assumption of control of the house was
it was a support to the general petraeus
an existing strategy but certainly the
wing of the Republican Party that with
the Tea Party syndrome and a potential
move towards isolationism particularly
given the budget pressures that the
country's inevitably going to as the
rest of the world is going to come unto
on the democratic issue I'm surprised
that we haven't seen more of the
anti-war movement that very much focused
on Iraq transfer to Afghanistan I think
that's because Afghanistan whether it
should be called a war at all it's
certainly in mind you not a nine-year
war there was a three-week war in 2001
was then a six-year under resource
reconstruction or peace building effort
and that the war that has restarted is
two years but anyway in in the media it
is a nine-year war but so both parties
have the potential to divide and I think
the real challenges can some kind of
bipartisan consensus emerged on the need
for a political strategy going forward
really seems to be the key issue but i
do think increasingly that the budgetary
pressures are going to play a role and
therefore i think that provides both a
challenge and an opportunity to look at
how as much can be done or much smarter
effects can be done with far less money
in my view we could be spending ten
percent literally of the money and
getting bigger effects on the civilian
side not only by looking at afghan
revenue collection and its ability to
meet its not to pay us back but to meet
its own costs going forward but even the
amount that's being spent externally to
invest much more smartly in building
Afghan capacity rather than basically
giving subsidies to contractors NGOs and
UN agencies yes
seemed to hear basically in one
consensus and so on and so forth and so
my question is what do you think the
WikiLeaks is going to do in respect to
developing consensus and the feelings
about wants to I have no comparative
advantage in that question either I
don't thought I think it's a disaster
but now that doesn't add any information
but I actually I agree was out this
morning I mean more damage was done more
damage was done by by this book you know
this damn Woodward book and then by
WikiLeaks me everybody knew that the
Pakistanis are affiliates there's no big
lesson in that in that stuff but but the
leaking of really essential the core
discussions of the national security
strategy for that ganna stand by the
people who collaborated with there will
be the Woodward book just appalls me so
if Jean Marie is right and we have a few
more years to walk to as we way to this
messy process we probably have at least
to take six years we have three more
would read books log and you have to
separate for well it is so thanks this
was very helpful I really appreciate it
presentations I wanted to ask something
that about what Claire la carta which I
mean I think you've said that the
government is going to become
self-supporting relatively soon well
there's the potential to do that no the
latter not i don'ti going to on the
current trajectory because the policy
frameworks are not in place it has the
potential to if the right decisions are
made if that's if if that is true then
that substantially revises our current
perception of the opportunities of the
afghan state and the u.s. participation
right if the if the if the Afghans say
it stops being what it currently is what
most people seem to think it is which is
a joint criminal enterprise I mean that
seems to be the mornings consensus and
becomes an actual state that can support
a security force then I think that
that's a major change and I would be
curious to hear a little bit more about
how we could make that happen it also
make makes me think of if you listen to
some army people Marines other US
military the way that they think about
capacity building in some cases is to
help local officials spend us money
exactly and so you know in thinking
about this the Afghan state is an actual
state which collects revenues is one way
out of that how could we distribute that
sort of thinking more widely Claire I'm
happy to talk sort of further afterwards
in the interest of time but I think it's
absolutely critical and dr. ghanian I'd
work says there's one measure of state
effectiveness or sovereignty its revenue
because so much else it's the
relationship between citizens estate
it's the ability to pay for your costs
so it's absolutely fundamental and
certainly might one of my big surprises
and reading the Woodward book is the
fact and since confirmed that revenue
collection didn't come up once in ten
presidential discussions of the country
so the whole economic agenda and in
discussions with srs geez we've dealt
with peace agreements around the world
when I
ask them what their biggest regret in
any of these cases was it was too faded
to deal with the physical and the
economic situation yeah but their regret
was that they didn't deal with it enough
because what happens if you ignore the
economy young men don't have jobs and
young women but it's the men who pick up
the guns you don't generate the revenue
to pay for the future costs and it's not
that no economy happens you get a
criminal economy affects the politics
tips you back into some form of civil
war or conflict so incredibly important
issue and exactly how do we shift it
around from in two ways one is instead
of seeing the external role in helping
the Afghan spend us money how do we flip
that around and actually maybe bringing
knowledge and expertise from the outside
and very targeted limited ways to help
the Afghans raise and spend their own
money so shift the focus and the
aperture on the domestic revenue flow
management of assets and expenditure
it's a critical shift in mental model
and goal that needs to take place and
you're the very fact that the UN in the
World Bank call went huge if we didn't
have the UN we'd have to reinvent it
what they do on the political side and
peace agreements is fundamental and is
indispensable but on the economic side
that the track record isn't good the
very fact that it's called a needs
assessment when the World Bank in you in
approach your country instead of looking
at the assets that are there and how to
mobilize and and let them come to
fruition I think we need to change that
dimension and one very concrete
recommendation is to 2000 125 wasn't
perfect but the World Bank the Asian
Development Bank and the IMF pretty much
had oversight of the economic agenda in
2006 almost by accident they were
knocked out of the way a un rle was
crafted around the personality of paddy
ashdown who wanted the keys to the
economic side he then didn't turn up for
various reasons so the UN was saddled
with the responsibility for the economic
side without the personality to manage
it the consequence of knocking out the
if' eyes means that the economic slipped
off the agenda I don't think Kabul Bank
Fiasco would have happened if the IMF
and the World Bank were doing their job
if you have the IMF of the World Bank
need to be there not perfect
institutions but it means the US doesn't
need to play bad cop on on
the accountability issue so much so
bringing the economic agenda and the
right actors to players is crucial part
of the way forward building on your
remark about the fact that we are going
to fight and negotiate at the same time
probably in the coming years I wonder if
the these tournaments are really
integrated in the current strategy my
point is that I don't feel that the
current fight is reinforcing in Kandahar
is reinforcing the Afghan state or is
helping the Taliban to go to the
negotiation on the contrary my feeling
is that the way the contents urgency is
working right now is radicalizing the
Taliban and weakening cause I actually
and so my question is don't you think
that we have to rethink the way we are
doing confidential whatever i'm in the
media operation to prepare the
negotiation for example if you shift the
major the major operation towards the
defense of Kabul for example because if
Kabul is stable then Kara is in a better
situation to negotiate with the tremor
so I think there is a deep contradiction
here and and I would like to have your
opinion I would simply agree with you
emphatically I mean this is I would
think that was my last point which maybe
I made incoherently which is that all
the lines of operation including how you
fight should be geared to high respect
to bring about a political solution that
achieves your desired objectives so how
you use special forces who you target
how many you target where you deploy
your forces how you use how you build up
the ANSF where you deploy them
everything should be geared in some
logical sets to to your strategy for
political solution well I also agree
with with Jim actually I I think that
there is a fundamental difference
between thinking that you can just cut
the mean as was said by my one of him
and I think by you actually that you can
just cut the Taliban in smaller pieces
and then swallow them or whether you yes
you do keep military pressure but you
don't have as a goal notion that you're
going to fragment more and more the
chain of command because at some point
you do need to have interlocutors and
unit you need to enter actors in a
national framework and I think there
they are for the moment there is no
agreement on that and I think it will it
will probably come from an evolution of
military operation and the recognition
that genuine political process is is
needed but we are not there yet if there
are no oh yes please
I was in here for the morning panel so
maybe some of this may have been
discussed may not have liked my my
understanding from the panels that I
have attended is that everything is in
flux like you know whether we had
panelists who looked at the past and you
know hindsight is 2020 and you know we
have people now looking you know Condrey
what's what's in the future and from
what I get everything is in flux so I
will America you know pull out of
afghanistan will it will it you know
retreat will it abandoned and if so will
they will it change like how it conducts
wars because they the thing i want to
think the thing i want to wonder about
is that was where we justified in going
in the way we did in the first place
will america change how it goes about i
mean if we don't we're basically going
to go back into another couple of
afghanistan or what have you so I'm just
saying or is there something like the UN
could do I mean or you know that could
we have some international law that
would prevent something like this
happening because I mean we're just
going to be repeating cycle with it so
I'm just curious have we learned
anything because I think way but what I
would say is I think the lack of clarity
on strategic intentions of the United
States with respect to get through
Afghanistan and the whole region is not
good that it's very important to have a
sense I mean in a way that was said by
Kelly ambassador Cal is that this
morning in a different way it's very
important to have a sense of direction
along the key the key players because if
you don't have that every play is going
to hedge and to prepare for various
scenarios and that in itself is deeply
destabilizing so that clarity is
necessary if you want to gradually
create the foundations of a serious
political process I'm going to say
something Nora I absolutely agree and I
think we see something of a shift to
from a July 11 date being the drop-dead
date and add as a result of the lisbon
summit for 2014 being more of a
realistic point in time to think about
transition I don't see transition and as
I think people aren't talking about exit
little met transition I see that as a
good thing in the sense that it
clarifies that the US presence is not an
occupation lot intended to be an
occupation it's intended to now people
see the critical path that has led to
where everybody is now we would choose
to be where they are now but it's now
about transition to Afghan sovereignty
and I think we've also seen movements to
looking at a strategic partnership with
Afghanistan and looking out to the five
and ten-year frameworks but I think on
the whole government's anywhere and not
good at planning this is a sort of move
away from grand strategy of all sorts of
reasons
and governments themselves around the
world of the prisoner of the sort of
four or five years cycle of democratic
politics and and thinking about ten and
twenty year time perspectives is very
difficult for anybody to do but its
necessary I think on this answer we will
close the conference and thank all the
panelists for what has been I think